ehi ehi ciao ragazzi dai gusti pazzi
come stiamo
cos'è sto radical summer che è successo
bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti avessero
video sono un paio geoges e un son
rocket league non solo cosa sbloccato
però un piccione sull'antenna poi un
canarino e tenero era un po ragazzi che
non facevo vino solo che twigg così puro
carico nel mentre che discutiamo nelle
nostre vite e volevo farlo perché mi
dava di farlo oggi mi sono portato qui
il mio power up per vincere che pietro
allora ragazzi negli anni non l'ho mai
abbandonato perché è veramente
incredibile e sono contento di che molti
di voi me lo chiedono motivano a
chiedermelo perché è uno dei pochissimi
giochi che non mi stanca mai potrei
giocarci anche a 80 anni proponiamo la
prima partita di non perderla che se no
cambiamo gioco giochiamo
va bene allora dovrei avere una persona
in grado di oggi ragazzi vorrei parlarvi
del bassone
e successo a milanello entra ciao step
tutto bene sto regia e flick di qualcosa
ai miei
ragazzi ciao papà stefano rompe durante
un gameplay va bene come un titolo
abbastanza gbyte si funziona però potevi
mettere tipo che ti ho impedito di
vincere la partita sto perdendo uno è
colpa di tutto è colpa mia
ecco il pezzo non segno che mi mangio le
banane ma è per quello no perché devi
sapere che io sto cercando di
autoalimentarsi con le proteine cosa che
non è molto semplice perché
come funziona funziona che se tu mangi
una banana e la partita inizia prendi
gol e quello che è successo perché è
velato anche per e inconsapevole di cosa
sta accadendo
va bene sta facendo un video bloccato il
video del video tu pensi visto ed è
colpa mia se perde la partita era ma
scusami
allora avevamo appuntamento alle 24 e 36
registrando ho detto guarda che mi fai
prendere gol guarda gli sguardi breve e
quindi ho detto aver registra un video e
mentre che arrivano a niente sono
arrivati nel mentre per rovinarmi la
partita è tutto un piano perché se le
merita queste cose prima di farlo
attraverso il mio in pace era un ritardo
di 5 minuti non farlo più che la vede
dovuto grazie va bene va bene allora
niente ragazzi scusate vi sono io che
sono troppo severo ecco io in genere
quando giocano petrini discuto della mia
vita e quindi ok scooter e nel fatto che
a me youtube un po ma cambiato corso
degli eventi insomma della mia vita non
era quello che pianificava quindi già
che ci sono
volevo chiederti se anche per testa per
così è diventata un intervista io bello
bello e interessante allora che la [ __ ]
e nel senso io giocherò che spensierato
e quindi parlo dei miei ragazzi quando
giocano che secondo parole dei ragazzi
dico queste cose è una cosa nuova in
realtà è più episodi e tu mi sei
subentrato nel primo però va beh non fa
niente chi se ne frega
vedremo la qualità di titolo estero
io volevo dirti che almeno per me poi
non so quanto te ne freghi però in
realtà nella mia vita io sono sempre e
mi conosci già un po di soldi sai che
sono una persona che non c'è molti piani
no quindi quello che mi succede e cerco
di tirare via al meglio è quello che è
successo con youtube perché alla fine io
volevo divertirmi stato mio compagno
abbiamo preso gol io me ne vado che sono
forti le famiglie dichiara guerra
l'italia in 33 st 6 4 1 4 1 sono mini
stavano per insultare quindi sono uscito
ma vieniva facciamo un optional scusa
fare almeno finisco questo video nei
migliori dei modi ma tranquilla tante
non voglio neanche giocare bene diciamo
scusa se amico bio allora adesso che sei
tu anche in partita posso darti la colpa
direttamente per scemo stavo parlando
corso del fatto che comunque a me come
l'ho presa e bravo che amo grasso che
oggi nasca da broda dato che mi ha dato
la possibilità di genere e volevo
rompere tenere di più le scattere questa
partita era anche ai lanciato invece
grazie grazie amico mio
qual è la t3 tutte le faccio io dai non
fa niente piero lontanissimo dicevo è
tra i nostri cani sono sono abbastanza
alti voglio dire quindi posso fare
questo discorso con te credo di trovarci
un dialogo decente quindi se sì come mi
chiedono molto come è cambiata la mia
vita da quando ha iniziato youtu.be
adesso te lo chiedo anche a te mentre
facciamo un tiro compiuto perché gli la
prima volta fa rispondere a me che
ancora non l'ho detto
ti togli la papi e grazia in evidenza
arrivano evitare questo tipo il meme
nessuno due punti allora la mia vita su
youtube è iniziata perché non avevo
nulla da fare come molti di voi ragazzi
ancora oggi sperano dei modi per
intrattenersi tipo ascoltando sfera e
basta o non so altre persone oggi voglio
fare tutti i rapper una volta lo fa fare
tutti youtubers non so se ancora così
c'è sicuramente si è scritta da questa
cosa esatto sicurezza non mette meta
meta meta ai tempi io
volevo fare questa cosa perché stava
andando di valletta più di quando c'era
solo me la godo allora mio compagno di
classe mi ha detto ciao perché non
facciamo ciao ciao
perché non facciamo un canale youtube
dove non c'era la ue e la webcam oggi
come la vedete che ci escono i miei
capelli la webcam tutto un processo
evolutivo dell'essere umano ma potresti
morire per quello che è appena fatta dal
processo evolutivo che non è andato
troppo oltre e niente quindi inizio
c'era solo commentari si chiamano così e
poi da cosa nasce cosa iniziato a fare
gli horror quindi con giorno dei mette
la vecchia perché tu che ti cali addosso
fa ridere e quindi si metterà webcam e
poi siamo arrivati qua oggi con youtube
non sono diventato indipendente vivo da
solo non c'è mia madre che mi ascolta
mentre mimic urlo come una [ __ ] quindi
sono tutte cose che sono a mia mamma mia
pianterà pesante quella roba e base cose
ma mi limitava tantissimo oggi che
giampiero mi dà una mano al montaggio
video io posso liberarmi grazie già però
che sta montando questo video
insomma sono molto più libero e
indipendente grazie al fatto che mi
hanno sempre tutti i miei follower
supportato solo non sarebbe per se non
fosse per loro non sarei qua
questo che gol ha fatto è stata
veramente resto che gol ha fatto
scusatemi se guarda che gol con che
classe poi e quindi niente per oggi
siamo siamo diventati insomma quello che
siamo diventati per me
bel gol non fosse per te così anche
perché tu non so quando ho iniziato io
ti parlo del 2012
allora lui mi sa che eravamo 2014 è
detto però è la webcam era la normalità
l'abbiamo messa ha fin da subito subito
vero eravamo terribili cento volte
meglio non averla io prima o poi ti farò
vedere i primissimi video che esistono
nostri tipo mi chiameresti per un
funerale e sarei adatto per odio lorente
i vari brutto e vabbè ma si cambiano il
senso anche io se mi guardi come parlavo
ce l'ho scritto io avevo l'olio nei
capelli vada con tutto un altro discorso
però è si migliora insomma youtube e
migliora la gente cioè ti fa avere un
lucido perché è chiaro noi da verdini
non è che ci siano sempre curati
l'aspetto però dal momento in cui si
guarda la gente diciamo che forse non vi
devono sembrare crudelia de mon quindi
anche cose non è che ci stiamo troppo e
di essere ben sapete è un certo se non
ci stavamo su youtube
vinciamo guarda che bravo bravo
maledizione questo è un tipo cavolo
questo il tiro ragazzi la portiamo a
casa almeno questo poi tra l'altro io
che sono anche una persona non so
textures aubry sono una persona molto
introversa no e quindi youtube oltre ad
avermi aiutato essere indipendente cioè
mi ha anche aiutato a parlare nel senso
che io so parlare adesso se sono sul
palco non me ne frega niente cioè come
se fossi davanti a mia mamma in tempo
parlare davanti alle persone mi emoziona
non vi sembra il già operato deve fare
tipo una chiacchierata sì perché sono
sono molto spensierato giocherà dei
plichi non è che mi impegno fin tanto
faccio streaming e segni wired farmi
vedere bellissima mi ha [ __ ] il tubo
era arrivato prima io
vai guardarlo proprio lui senza niente
senza legge la dignità non toccarla se
non toccava terra un'altra gara va bene
non fa niente se segnano io ti diseredo
bene ragazzi la chiudiamo così con un 1
v1 amichevoli non voleranno per niente
insulti o robe del genere mia card a
letto ma che cosa era arrivato che ho
preso male attenzione questa è tramite
un altro vero e proprio
la modalità basket e l'hanno migliorata
porca vacca quantica vita nel computer
che devo muovermi parco lo schifo la
partenza ha fatto schifo perché ho messo
la gamba in mezzo a mille e seicento
cavi che avevo nel computer
prendi questo può valere sentimento
anche difficoltà ti faccio le domande
qual è il pittore più famoso del 1600 è
lì che ti distrai non ci credo non puoi
non puoi mai cosa come l'ha messa dentro
e il filtro meglio oltre che la palla
sta tutto dentro per forza non parole
no non credo l'incredibile corà toglie
lui e la toglie nessuno palo non ci
posso credere non è vero non so se tu
amavi è stato bravo qua è stato bravo ma
è stato bravo io mai quello è lo scontro
aereo ma non si crea il futuro lo sanno
il segreto è xavi stato fermo qua perché
volevo parte però hai visti l'attuale
aerei aerei all
ma no insomma lasciato messo la faccia e
riparte proprio lui no invece a bordo ma
ora come ero contento di partire
fortissimo e poi tutto contento ma era
arrivato a ieri pastorale che non è
stato proprio una fregatura il canestro
dai è stato comunque la bella partita
sono contento di aver fatto una micro
chiacchiera fatemi sapere se volete
nelle chiacchiere per clicca mi piace
chiacchiere su rocket league
io ringrazio stefano aver partecipato
involontariamente a questo video che lo
fa allora solo poi subentrato va bene
per avere sia piaciuto però che sarete
un like al canale iscrivetevi piaciuta
la campanella così rimanete aggiornati
su novità è come sempre ragazzi ci
vediamo allora su variaz
[Musica]